good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 24 object class
Euclid special containment procedures
due to its nature SCP 24 cannot be moved
to a secure location so security
measures must be placed on site to
conceal its location five identical
looking replicas have been erected
around a CP 24 a tight security
perimeter must be maintained around a
cp24 compound at all times with separate
security teams guarding SCP 24 and it's
replicas none of the security teams
except for team leaders will be informed
of the location of SCP 24 24 must be
secured with magnetically sealed blast
doors and reinforced armored walls to
prevent unauthorized entry under no
circumstances can any security or
research personnel enter a CP 24 only
d-class personnel are allowed entry and
strictly for research purposes only all
researchers are to observe an experiment
with SCP 24 from the remote observation
lab any personnel attempting to leave
the remote observation lab or enter a CP
24 without prior approval from a level-4
researcher must be immediately
apprehended with termination authorized
should containment be breached or SCP 24
stru nature compromised then the entire
compound must be destroyed via
specialized demolition charges planted
throughout the compound
description SCP 24 is an abandoned
soundstage that was once owned but
however SCP 24 has been abandoned since
nineteen and that is unknown whether its
special properties manifested before or
after its abandonment SCP 24 is located
in the heart and was initially
discovered when a group of teenage
youths broke into the abandoned compound
the testimony of the lone winner when
she turned herself in to the police was
enough to have foundation assets
mobilized to contain a cp24 upon
entering a cp24 visitors are immediately
greeted by an anonymous announcer who
communicates via intercom and is able to
hear and comprehend the voices of people
within SCP 24 the announcer will inform
the contestants that they are about to
take part in a game show in which the
winners will win fabulous prizes but it
will also warn that the game will be
extremely hazardous and that the losers
will never leave a cp24
it is at this point that the announcer
presents the choice of whether to stay
or leave a cp24 contestants who accept
will continue to participate in the game
while those who decline are immediately
expelled from a cp24
contestants that win the game or
declined to participate may never enter
a cp24 again as entry is denied by an
impenetrable and visible barrier it is
then that the contestants are led to the
actual game the style composition and
appearance of the game always changes in
every individual playthrough but the
game is always centered around a long
elaborate obstacle course that the
contestants must navigate through the
rules also very some playthroughs may
only allow a single winner while others
encourage the creation of teams to win
the game
more often than not the obstacles seen
in these games range from incredibly
benign to extremely hazardous and
life-threatening as the contestants
attempt to negotiate the course the
announcer will continuously update their
status and actively participate in the
game often giving advice conversing with
contestants and adding new rules as the
game progresses the obstacles become
significantly more dangerous and
difficult to overcome and that is not
surprising to have the entire pool of
contestants succumb to the rigors of the
obstacle course if such an event happens
the announcer will express sadness at
the lack of a winner and a cp24 will
shut down resetting only when a new
batch of contestants enter any attempts
to break the rules such as assaulting
other contestants and deliberately
bypassing obstacles are met by extreme
violence an announcer will call out the
offending contestant who will be quickly
and forcefully ejected from the course
by studio Guardians these studio
Guardians will immediately materialize
within SCP 24 went called upon by the
announcer and disappear when not needed
the contestant will never be seen again
when a winner is declared he or she will
receive a random grand prize any
contestants that have survived the
course but failed to win are immediately
declared losers by the announcer the
lights will switch off and the winner
will immediately appear outside of SCP
24 with his or her prize while the
losers completely disappear however the
most mysterious aspect of SCP 24 is that
after every game a VHS tape or DVD will
appear in the mailbox out sign of
scp-2401 is a complete record of the
entire game that was previously played
even though winners have claimed that
they had never seen any cameras or
recording devices in sinus EP 24
also more strangely a live studio
audience can be seen in the background
cheering on the contestants again
winners have claimed not to have seen a
live studio audience while inside SCP 24
addendum one so far the list of prizes
awarded to winners has included but is
not limited to cash prizes electronics
various consumer goods cars collectibles
full paid vacations to various countries
close examination of these prizes have
confirmed that they are completely
genuine and possess no unusual abilities
or characteristics whatsoever there
appears to be no consistent pattern for
what the prizes will be addendum 2 in an
attempt to track where the losers were
taken GPS locator beacons were planted
on subjects d1 24 through d1 35 when
group d2 45 was sent into SCP 24 when
the losers were taken away all signals
from the beacons were lost whether this
is because the beacons were destroyed or
because the losers were taken to an area
that cannot be located via GPS is
currently unknown addendum 3 the
announcer living within SCP 24 to be
sentient and aware of events that take
place outside of the compound during the
test of Group d5 23 which consisted only
of dr. P the announcer instead engaged
in a conversation with dr. fool
analysis of the conversations have shown
that the majority of the subjects are
centered around pop culture and the
information distributed through
television implying that scp-2401 all
power and signal lines as well as
removing any potential wireless
receiving equipment on a cp24 does not
affect us EP 24 in any way
when it became clear that no other
contestants would participate the
announcer kindly asked dr. the leave SCP
24 and suggested he returned with more
contestants
addendums for the studio Guardians that
the announcer uses to enforce the rules
may vary in appearance every game just
like the course if they appear the
Guardians will always be dressed in a
manner that matches with the theme of
the obstacle course the only common
attributes all Guardians share are the
possession of human appearance ability
to suddenly appear and disappear
superhuman strength and face concealing
masks or headgear however winners have
claimed that the guardians have no
apparent shape or form in saina cp24
instead appearing as huge shadowy
figures that engulf the offender okay I
think that about does it for today thank
you all for listening if indeed you
still are and you were all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Bob the reclusive extrovert geum's
Sabah Chris all hens I'd Pablo ice 917
Karim L ash mooing Justin day Thomas
Morin Curie kuma white crew and jayvo
jack crystal spice my archive curator
Nick Joseph Lewis ooh eggy
King modding and the wanderer thank you
all so much for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos well on some other
cool stuff as well visit patreon.com
forward slash the Volgin thank you
you